Speaker 1: Let's see, why don't we speak next
to.
Oh, I don't know.
There was really just it's it's really a it's
it's hard to pick because there's so many
great people holding.
How about Ryan from El Paso, Texas?
Ryan, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hey, David, can you hear me all
right?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can, but discord is blinking
in the background.
That's the only issue.
Speaker 2: Oh, hold on a
Speaker 1: second, please.
Speaker 3: OK, so I'm I'm but I'm a bit of
a younger folk.
I'm a 13 year old, and I was just wondering
how I could get a little more politically
involved, you know, because most people don't
really know, like, you're just the kid you
don't really understand.
And I would just, you know, like I could sort
of just get myself out there.
Speaker 1: Beautiful.
This is a great question.
Getting involved at your age is an amazing
thing to do.
So my guess is most things you can't run for
right now because you probably need to be
18, but that doesn't mean you can't help out
on a campaign.
So what I would say is maybe starting right
in El Paso is there I don't know what the
system of government there is, but is there
a mayoral candidate you can help?
Is there a city council candidate that you
can help?
What about what's going on in school board?
Presumably you're going to be in school for
some some years.
What about figuring out who would you like
to work with for school board?
Is there school government that you could
maybe get involved in?
There's really a lot of options.
It's just a matter of knowing where to look.
Also, by the way, a lot of nonprofits that
you could volunteer for at age thirteen, you
might need a parent permission or something
like that.
A lot of nonprofits are working on political
issues.
So, like, if you're a political issue, you
care about is education or homelessness or
whatever, you can probably find a nonprofit
to volunteer with that would work on that
issue.
So there's really no shortage of ways to get
involved right now.
Speaker 2: OK, that's that was my only question.
Speaker 1: Thank you, David.
All right, Ryan, let let us know if you get
involved in something, OK?
OK.
All right, Ryan from El Paso, I have to tell
you, upper management written all over him
from what I'm hearing, 13 years old getting
involved.
I love it.
All right.
Why don't we go to Charlie from Ann Arbor,
Michigan, I presume.
Charlie from Ann Arbor, Michigan, you're on
the air.
Please don't break the streak of perfect phone
calls.
Charlie, we're on a roll here.
Oh, and Charlie's gone, we couldn't do it,
we almost, almost, almost had a perfect full
session without any dropped calls or.
That's really sad